It's time to take a deep breath.
We've covered a lot of
territory in this lesson.
We've learned about the core rationales
for HIT adoption, and we deepened
our understanding of the link between it
and success in managing chronic disease.
And how that link led to new federal
policies to encourage adoption.
We've learned that those polices
are divided into three interrelated
efforts to assure that EHRs
have key capabilities.
That they're used in a manner
that is believed will lead to
improved care coordination and
ultimately to improved outcomes.
And that financial incentives are there
to reimburse providers and hospitals for
the cost of these systems and to provide
ongoing incentives to use them properly.
We've seen that adoption levels
are quite high, but that survey data
reveals some dissatisfaction
with current EHR systems.
We'll look more deeply into why
that is the case in lesson six,
as we begin to look at real-world
applications of health IT in
the second half of the course.